[Musique]
dans ce livre on vous découvre
extrêmement proche de votre mari un
couple très fusionnelle à ce que vous
viviez un peu dans la peur avec tino
quai des menaces oui d intimidation
comme brûler les locaux oui mais un
assassinat vraiment jeune ans je pense
que j'y croyais pas ceux qui ont été
assassinés étaient les politiques du
journal il était l'âme de ce journal et
oui ils ont tué charlie je voulais pas
que tignes où ce soit une victime
je voulais pas que son nom soit associé
à 8 e-news la victime de charlie je
voulais que l'on se dise à tignes où le
grand dessinateur c'est ça qui est bien
avec un artiste c'est qu'un artiste tant
qu'on publie son travail l'artiste est
vivant
[Musique]